foreign
Cincinnati Ohio what's up Jessica
hey there um thank you so much for
taking my call absolutely thanks for
calling
I'm currently on baby step two and I'm
in the process of taking care of some
pretty decently large Consumer Debt that
I had accrued while I struggled with
some depression in the last couple of
years but my issue is that with making
some of the necessary sacrifices that
I've had to make I've gotten a lot of
flack from some friends and family for
saying no to going out and then they'll
offer to pay for me just so I do get out
so how do I start to assert those
boundaries because it makes me really
uncomfortable when they offer to pay
yeah you two two ways forward okay
number one
coming out of a depression a depressive
season and getting well you ha that's an
agreement with your body that we're
gonna feel this discomfort and we're
gonna head into it not away from it okay
so saying no saying I can't make it and
having somebody say I want you here so
bad because we like you that I'll just
grab your the cost of your meal and that
shame that discomfort that I'm not worth
that I'm not enough they're just pitying
me those are feelings that we are going
to for the first time we're gonna feel
them actually
we may write them down
we may look at them and demand evidence
from am I are they really asking me to
come out and pay for my meal because
they Pity Me are they really just feel
sorry for me or am I their friend and
they see that their friend like so what
dude I'm just gonna grab your meal I'd
much rather have you hang out than have
twenty dollars burning a hole in my
wallet and so the first thing is you're
going to have to begin to feel those
feelings discomfort that's the key to
getting healthy okay walking through
little tiny steps through those feelings
the second thing is you're gonna have to
make peace with missing something
sometimes and not being so prideful
that you skip out on friendships just
because you don't want to have their
help see what I'm saying
yeah I do I think it's worth going out
sometimes and letting them grab your
food for you and by the way when when I
had a friend who was struggling deeply
with depression you know what I felt
most of the time completely helpless
and being able to grab dinner was like
something I could do
and so even if you don't like the idea
of somebody paying for your dinner or
grabbing your movie ticket
think of it as a gift to your friend
I'm helping them out by letting them
help me you know what I mean because it
gives them something to do because they
love you and they want to be a part of
your recovery they just don't know how
to do it they don't they don't have the
training or the professional whatever
they can give you 20 bucks to grab some
fajitas it's some nachos you know what I
mean
yeah I do
um and and for the friendships I think
that makes a lot of sense but I do come
from a family of like we give you a gift
and then we use it against you yes the
weapons
okay so exactly I want you to deal with
that put this in your back pocket the
things we did to keep ourselves safe and
alive when we were younger become the
things that destroy the relationships
our relationships as adults
so as a kid you knew that extra ice
cream is going to come with some garbage
attached to it
you knew when dad called and said you
can borrow 100 bucks for fill in the
blank that was going to come with some
heavy heavy costs
and so you learn to shut that down you
learn to say no I'll do this by myself
I'm going to be a Lone Ranger through
the rest of my life and then your body
said we can't live like this that's
depression
and now practicing relationships moving
forward
is you unlearning the things that kept
you alive when you were a kid or now the
things that are hurting you so we're
going to practice letting George buy me
dinner
because I know George isn't gonna you
know if George proves over time that he
is just using me or he expects something
in return cool I learned something about
my friendship with George I learned
something about George so I'm going to
quit right I'm not going to over
moralize it I'm not going to beat myself
up I'm not going to feel shame over it I
learned something about George he didn't
tell me the truth cool I'm just not
going to take uh food from him next time
I'm not going to let him pay for my
concert ticket next time awesome sure
that makes sense yeah it makes a lot of
sense yeah and I feel like I'm not the
only one that struggles with that
because you do everyone does yeah
everyone does we were George and I were
just talking about this off air
um that it's hard to
take something from somebody when we all
have that friend who's like um last year
I gave you 4.28 cents at Wendy's and you
owe me for gosh who likes you know what
I mean the worst impression of me ever
I'm not saying that was George but
that's for sure George
um that's why I love venmo right we can
just settle it right now we can all move
on with our lives
um there's something about practicing
those relational needs that we have as
young adults and into adulthood that are
completely opposite to what we needed to
do to survive when we were kids
okay and you deserve friends and
relationships and in fact if you're
healing from depression
a powerful strong loving community that
walks alongside you is the Cornerstone
of getting well okay yeah you're worth
that is that cool
yes thank you so much let him pay for
your dinner and and on those other
nights that you just can't get out of
bed feel free to say no that's cool or
tell them they can grab tacos and show
up at your house that'd be fantastic